doctors and nurses are being called out
of retirement to help their weary
colleagues CBS News medical contributor
dr. Tara Narula talked with Michelle
pedak own as she left her practice
she left her practice rather as a
respiratory therapist in Seattle that
was two years ago to teach at Upstate
Medical University that's in Syracuse
New York
she's now returning to the frontlines
what is it about now that compelled you
to want to reach out and come back into
the work force as a healthcare
professional it's it's a calling on my
heart I need to help because I believe
the systems are gonna be overwhelmed did
you have discussions with your family
about any safety concerns that you might
have for yourself or for them so as a
single mom I have discussed this with my
son because I wanted to make sure that
he understood everything he had seen me
out in the hospitals most most of his
life taking care of other people
and he said I could do it as long as I
didn't get sick which sounds like a
really good deal are you worried about
your own safety yes I think that's
normal I think a little apprehension
maybe a little fear and anxiety it can
be healthy in this situation are you
worried at all about bringing Kovac or
cranberries home to your son absolutely
but I also recognize that I could bring
it home up going to the grocery store
has your family said to you about
stepping up and back into the workforce
they called you a hero you know
interestingly enough my father did call
me a hero how did you feel hearing those
words from your father okay so I cried
for an hour and when I moved up was
there one moment that really made you
say I have to do this I think that one
moment just came and hit me from side to
side many times a day and seeing how
desperate the patients are and how
desperate my co-workers are there's no
way I could just sit home and and read
their stories not do something about it
and dr. Terry Narula joins us now doctor
good morning one of the moments for me
was when I was walking in my
neighborhood and there's an electronic
sign that the city puts out and it
actually was a call-out to medical
workers to return from retirement and
come to the front lines what's the
significance of that request and what
role might it play
well it's really inspiring to see how
many people are stepping up and this is
a strategy that's being used by
countries around the world and it's
truly an all-hands-on-deck approach we
know we have a finite number of health
care workers a growing number of
patients and really a dwindling supply
of health care providers either because
they are quarantined they're at home
taking care of their kids or many of
them are getting sick and when you look
at how many of them are getting infected
themselves the numbers are pretty
staggering over 3,000 health care
professionals infected in China over
4,000 in Italy over 5,000 in Spain and
you know we talk a lot about the supply
of masks and ventilators but those are
things that you know when we decide to
we can ramp up production relatively
quickly it's not so the case with our
health care providers it takes years and
years to train doctors and nurses and
other health care professionals what
about the health care professionals who
have retired are there concerns about
their age and there may be underlying
symptoms that they may have absolutely I
mean we know that about 40% of doctors
and nurses are over the age of 55 and as
we've discussed the older you are the
more underlying conditions you have the
more at risk you are for having a severe
consequence or case of kovat that being
said we're trying to figure out where to
put these retirees that might be safer
some of people who are discussing using
them in telehealth capacities now that
those rules have changed they can
provide care across state lines or in
areas where they wouldn't be directly
you know facing patients or dealing with
patients you know what struck me Tara
your interview with Michelle pedak oh
and when she said it's a calling on my
heart I think a lot of people in your
profession feel that way it's a calling
on my heart that was really lovely
absolutely and you know last week mayor
de Blasio said that over a thousand
people in New York City signed up in one
day to help out and it's not just our
retirees that we're seeing step up its
medical students as well many of them
are helping to organize supply drives
for masks they're babysitting the kids
of doctors that are called to the front
line and NYU just announced that they're
going to graduate students early to help
out if they
you know everything helps during this
time Thank You Tara